you're known to lick your fan done now
what let's talk about that let's talk
about that you lick your fans how did
that start
why did it start how do I get in on that
you know it it started because I started
licking my castmates
and Denise Huth who was one of our
producers and then she would don't lick
me and it became a thing and then I went
to London and I took a bunch of selfies
with monuments and stuff where I was
licking monuments are like Charlie
Chaplin guys on the street or whatever
and then it became I would call it urban
dictionary there which i think is what
that shirts about right there this is a
very attractive woman saying Norman
please read us me yeah yeah that's your
call
you know I yeah I mean yeah the bowler
right what the heck put up all right
yeah I mean but sometimes like you know
dads will come up to me with their
daughters and be like look my daughter
you know or go ahead lick him I get that
too you know that's just being on
television don't you really you have
dads that come up and they say lick my
daughter that's yeah you know it was
crazy I had one guy that came up to me
he goes I'm gonna take a picture right
and pulls out of a rubber horse head and
he goes okay you're gonna get on my back
and you're gonna you're gonna ride me
around the room and I'm like no I'm not
and then he looks over at his friend and
he goes he won't even do it and then his
friend takes his rubber horse head and
goes
take one he's no fun going to work where
the horse had just to take the picture
yeah man I just I can't do something
really quick yeah happy birthday mom I
like how you gave the sign of the devil
you got to make my mom fantastic
you